Sports Illustrated in is in Hot
Water Sports Illustrated is in hot water
because futurism another outlet has just
done an investigation and accused Sports
Illustrated of publishing articles
generated by AI futurism then asked
Sports Illustrated about the alleged AI
written articles and then they deleted
everything oo they got them right it's a
long expose I didn't read the whole
thing I don't really see why I would
because I don't see why I would care I
hate to defend Sports Illustrated Sports
Illustrated has gone super lib why do I
care if some computer wrote up content
if I like the content I probably don't I
don't read Sports Illustrated but if if
the content itself is fine why do I care
if it was written by a computer or by a
human being I'll go further I bet that
AI is capable of writing much more
interesting instructive edifying
articles than many so-called journalists
today